all right so good morning everyone
they did not tell me that the walkway by
uh parliament was closed so i had to go
all the way around so that's why i'm
just
a little late getting here no worries
though
um so yes my name is jimmy bogard you
can find me on twitter at jbogard um you
can find this code this probably the the
presentation and all the slides on my
github at github.comguard there's a
presentations repository there um i blog
about this and a lot of other topics on
my blog at jimmybogart.com
so yes
before we get
too far into
domain different refactoring i want to
talk a little bit about what
domain-driven design is
um just if you had to do a little bit of
level sets um actually let me see if i
can
one second
now
and trying to extend
there we go so i can actually read my
notes
and
okay yes there we go
so from the domain driven design book
although it's um you know that domain
driven design book has a lot of great
definitions of things it doesn't
actually provide a great definition of
domain driven design so this is one
where i kind of had to like glom things
together from a couple sources just to
try to get it in one single sentence but
domain driven design in one sentence is
an architectural design strategy
in which we selectively distill organize
and abstract the body of knowledge from
the users to the software and there's
kind of three key words there one is to
selectively distill so we're not trying
to take like everything that's possible
in the real world everything is possible
that the users are doing everything
that's possible in the business and try
to put that in software because that's
impossible we never finish writing
software
so we're trying to pick and choose what
are the most important things to be able
to represent in our software
the second one is to organize so trying
to avoid the big ball of mud mess um and
trying to organize it in such a way that
also makes sense to the business as well
maybe not from like a complete software
perspective but at least like that they
under like the things that how things
relate to each other the different kind
of components that those have somewhat
analogs in the real world as well
and the final one is to abstract
and the reason why we need to abstract
is the real world can be
really really complicated
and so you probably know when you talk
to your business or users and they they
start talking about how the you know how
they do their business and how they
accomplish certain tasks and they'll
just start like rambling on and on and
on and going on and on forever and like
well we can't do all of that so we need
to kind of like take a step back and say
well what are the kind of main themes
that do we have here and that's that
that third part is abstraction
and so
the three things here we're trying to
distill
organize and abstract is really what
domain-driven design is all about
and one of the big key components of
domain driven design is this domain
model that represents the kind of object
model of
the business
so even the idea of a domain model
actually predates domain-driven design
in the martin fowler book patterns of
enterprise application architecture he
describes a
a domain model as an object model of the
domain that incorporates both behavior
and data
and so there's two key components there
there's the data parts which i think all
of us kind of get more or less right
the second part is the more complicated
part the behavior part
because most
systems i see that
like try to get the names right and try
to get the data rights
they don't have the behavior part of it
and so uh that's okay um this talk all
is all about what are those systems look
like that we don't have the behavior in
the right parts we don't have the
behavior
in the domain model itself instead the
behavior is kind of scattered all around
the system and so that's what most of my
systems i see uh wind up is like okay
yes the maybe the names aren't even
right
but
uh the the behaviors there just kind of
all scattered about
but that's okay um we can follow the the
normal test driven design steps of red
green refactor um or most legacy code
that i see is just like what tests
and then just refactor
now this is where
in terms of techniques and how to
accomplish this
these are none of the things i'm going
to be showing today are things that i
made up myself although i guess i could
take credit for them someone would call
me out on twitter and then it'd be a
whole thing
these are all things that have been and
all techniques that have been well
documented over the years
and there's three main books that i work
from to pull together techniques to to
build out my domain models uh the main
one i work with is working effectively
with legacy code um which really is just
like how do you refactor code without
tests which is a lot of legacy code that
i see these days and by the way he
defines legacy code as just code without
tests because it's hard to change
the other two great books uh of course
are martin fowler's refactoring book
over there on the left uh the second
edition is javascript so yeah whatever
and then um one that's actually out of
print unfortunately but it's my favorite
design patterns book is joshua foreski's
book on refactoring to patterns and all
these books take the concept of instead
of like gang of four having like here is
like the here's just the list of
patterns and you just kind of pick and
choose whatever you want to go from or
like more of these prescriptive styles
it said if you just get your code and
this structure and this organization
then everything's going to be fantastic
but i i found that in like real world
applications there's no there's no
structure or organizational style or set
of patterns you can blindly apply to
have good code at the end instead we
have to get good at these techniques
described in these books to build out
good domain models
so
i'm going to be working with a
a a current system or current
application that more or less
represented one that i was working with
uh years ago so just want to walk
through the current state of this
application this the sample code that we
have right now
so this sample code is dealing with a uh
a loyalty reward system and in a loyalty
reward system we have uh we have a few
major components and some of you are
probably like actually probably all of
you are part of one of these things like
uh you go to boots and they're like are
you part of our preferred club member or
whatever in exchange for like your
personal information um and like all
your spending habits and all your data
they'll give you like a discount every
other month or so so there's a little
bit of an exchange there of like give up
a little bit of privacy and here's some
discounts or whatever and that's what
this system was represented
so this is just a class diagram of our
our current quote domain model
over on the left here we have our member
object
and so right away we we can see like
we're not uh we're not trying to
represent everyone in the world so we
don't have like a person
object here or a human object and so
there's that again that distillation we
have a member object that is
representative of a member in this
system not just any person walking down
the street because not every person in
the world is a member of this system
only people that have like opted in and
said i will give you my personal
information are part of the system
we also have offers
now offers are those like discounts
given to individual members
and so as part of this
each offer can have some kind of type
and this is kind of like the the
metadata associated with an individual
offers so offer types are things that
someone's going into some kind of
back-end management application and and
configuring and saying we're going to
have this opera this time and oh it's a
jubilee so we're going to do a jubilee
offer or whatever
so those are all configured in the offer
types and then when i go to actually
assign an offer to a member that's one
of these these offers popped into play
so from this we can also uh we can also
infer that the offer is associated with
an individual member
and we can see that by those different
associations there
that a member has a collection of
assigned offers and an offer can only be
assigned to one member and so the idea
there is that if i uh assign a single
offer to a single member then no one
else can then
use that offer
so i could show this to the business
and even though they don't kind of
understand like like what does class
mean necessarily and what do these weird
carrots mean and what is a little i
don't even know what that little gear
means but whatever
that they they can look at the names of
these things and the relationships and
that makes it would make sense to them
like oh yes we
have offers assigned to a member um we
have member information there everything
looks great right
even the names of the associations match
the names of the relationships in the
real world it's not just member has
offers well what like what is the nature
of that relationship their assigned
offers so they could look at this and
say yep that looks that looks all
correct and by the way if it doesn't
look correct in your domain model that's
still possible to like refactor towards
i won't go to that in this talk but it's
still perfectly possible to take names
that don't match and then make them
match um
through a series of steps so they could
look at this and say yep everything
looks great so ship it
but there's one problem here
you'll notice that
my domain model only has properties
there's no methods
there are methods but i hid them from
the picture there's like
equals and git hash code and those
aren't really like domain behaviors but
they're they're technically methods but
i hit them because it would be confusing
here but there's no actual like beha
like domain behavior on these objects
whatsoever
but that's not like that's not the whole
behavior does exist in this system
but where is the behavior
well it could be in
let's see member controller dot post it
could be in uh button click dot save or
button save dot click or button save
underscore click if you're gosh and
webford's lan it could be in like
uh react code it could be in like uh
member manager member helper member you
know insert you know generic object here
um so that that that behavior definitely
exists in the system my system is not
doing nothing it's not just like showing
data on the screen and that's it um
there's going to be some behavior
associated with the system
but it's just not in the domain model
instead it's scattered about the
application
so i have to go find where the behavior
is in this case i've got like a services
folder and that's wrong like just
dumping ground of all the logic of my
application and that's where i'll
actually find the real behavior
all right so now let's switch over to
the code
and walk the refactoring of some of
these services
okay
so over here on the right
i've got my model that we showed earlier
so the names all match blah blah blah
and then the services folder that's
where like the real behavior of my
application is
and if you want to get technical like
the the design pattern being used for my
current services is known as a
transaction script and let's look at one
of these different actions to see what's
going on here and what i look at first
is this one says assign offer handler so
that sounds like it's the handling the
logic of assigning an offer
probably to a member
nope
there we go
all right i'll go ahead and hide that
all right so the first thing i like to
do in one of these kind of like i'm
looking at a class for the first time is
to look at the using statements to
understand what are the what are the
typical what are the things that this
this class is working with
um and so you see kind of the normal
ones like using system well it's hard to
get away from that um then we see using
system net http so that's telling me
that it's using web services or some
kind of http directly here right it's
like using http client probably directly
inside of here not probably i know it is
um now it's using system text json okay
so it's calling a web service and
probably having to deserialize some junk
as well
threading threading tasks like can't get
away from that anymore that's all over
the place
it's also using the model and it's also
using mediator but that's like
immaterial for all of this
the next thing i like to do is then look
at the constructor and hopefully
it's using dependency injection so i can
see what are the different classes that
this object uses in order to perform its
work
and i saw the one piece which was http
client so yes that confirmed their
suspicions that it's calling out to a
web service
and the other thing of course it's going
to be using is entity framework so it's
got this app db context and that's where
that before model namespace came from is
it's giving us
that db context there so
it's calling web services and it's doing
data access that's like you know 95 of
the actions in the system probably it's
doing data access and maybe calling out
to a web service
all right
so this class has one single method
called handle and you can kind of
imagine that this class is like this is
the main action that executes when
someone like clicks a button on a screen
or whatever so i've tried to remove it a
little bit from like controllery stuff
or or front any stuff and just like kind
of meat of the actual request work being
done here
so it takes an input of a request object
so this represents like all the input
parameters to do this work and that
request object has just two properties
the member id and the offer type id so
i'm i am assigning an offer to a member
so i need to know what kind of offer i'm
needing to assign and who should i
assign it to so those are those two
things
then finally we get to the actual meet
of the request
so the first two lines here
uh those are just any framework junk i
need to load up the actual member object
and load up the offer type object um
that's going to be like again like 99 of
the actions in my system i first have to
like load the data up to be able to work
with it
and so that's going to be pretty much
the same everywhere
and now i see the actual meat of the
method and the first kind of clue that
maybe this method is a little too long
are code comments
code comments are a good clue of like
okay if this method got too long someone
was like someone had the
foresight enough to like try to break it
up into individual parts of the app of
the method and try to document okay
these are the here are the different
steps that are happening so step one it
looks like it's to calculate offer value
and as part of calculating the offer
value it oh here we go here's where it's
actually calling out to some made-up web
service
to pass in the member's email and the
offer type and it'll give me back the
actual value of the offer
maybe there's some third party system
that you know keep strike has like data
aggregation machine learning blah blah
blah
i don't know what's going on behind the
scenes but i do know give it the email
give it the type and will give me the
offer
offer value
so at the very end
the end result is i get a value for the
offer
next up is calculating the expiration
dates
all right so this looks like uh based on
the expiration type
there's two different kinds there's an
assignment type and a fixed type
uh it looks like assignment type is
based on
when i sign the offer to you you have x
number of days to use it and then it's
no longer valid like maybe it's your
birthday and you have
20 days from your birthday i don't know
to be able to use it and so that one uh
goes up based on when you sign it and
then there was a fixed expiration type
so that is
it's good for the month of may so it's
it's done may 30th
and finally we have like the actual
interesting part which is assigning an
offer to a member so we have a first
where it's uh instantiating the offer
object
then we assign the offer to the well no
actually we add the offer to the assign
offers collection on the member
and then this is kind of a weird thing
where we're keeping track of the number
of active offers and it's probably
because we displayed that in a lot of
places or we use it for calculations or
something like that and so we want to
pre-calculate that uh so it makes it
much easier for us to be able to display
it or use that information instead of
having to actually you know join all the
time to be able to get that information
and finally the boring ef core stuff
where i have to
add the offer to the db set thing i
guess and then save the changes
using the db context
so looking at this when i see this like
this kind of
long method that has a bunch of stuff
going on
my first kind of instinct is to try to
break up this method into individual
smaller components so i can better
reason about it now this isn't
necessarily something i keep all the
time like i don't necessarily like put
it in and keep it forever but just to
kind of help help me to reason about
what are these different steps that are
going on here and how do they relate to
each other
so let's do that first
i want to break apart each of these like
major sections of the of the method and
just extract these into individual
methods
so i'm going to be using by the way i'm
using resharper i saw an advertisement
for a resharper there are certain things
in here that are only achievable via
resharper and paid tools i'll highlight
those when i get to them
but i don't get paid by them whatsoever
it's just i can't refactor with the
hungry sharper these days so here we are
all right so
we have member and offer type and
cancellation token of course we need a
name or method so i'm going to call it c
um oh that's a good click a good who
clue hint um
the code comment said calculate offer
value so maybe we just called method
that calculate
calculate offer value
okay that was reasonable enough
let's do the same for the second method
the second section here
to extract this into let's see that code
comment was
calculate expiration date let's do the
same thing
expiration date
all right and finally the assign offer
part
assign offer
so all this helps me do is just
be a little bit more
to have a little bit more understanding
about what are the different steps is in
each of these different uh parts of the
method
and also to understand what do each of
those different steps use as part of
their logic
so each of these methods has
parameters being input into them so
that's like here are the things i need
to run
um
when i look at the individual methods
also notice like is it using any of the
dependencies being passed in the
constructor
and then how do the different steps
relate to each other so does one value
feed into the next one and we can see
that here that the first value feeds
into the third method the second value
also feeds into the third method and the
third method then does all the work
so this pattern right here is known as
the transaction script pattern the ideas
that have
individual methods of representative
classes that represent the overall
actions in my application and each of
those actions
has a transaction around it and then the
inside part is in all the business logic
now for a lot of applications and
systems that i deal with this is good
enough like it's it's okay not to make
it any better than this
if the code smells inside of the
application or inside the method don't
lead us down those different uh
different directions
so i in my systems i always still start
with with this exact pattern just make
it as dumb and as simple as possible but
when things start to get more complex
and i start to see more behavior as part
of that that's when i start to use these
refactoring techniques
so
if i just stopped here this would be a
very short talk so let's keep going
so i'm going to do is take each of these
methods one by one
look at the logic inside of it and we're
going to decide where should that logic
belong does it belong here in this class
does it belong in a different class does
it belong in the domain model let's take
a look
all right the first one is calculate
offer value
okay so as the parameters i see member
offer type and cancellation token of
course because it's an async method
the other thing i noticed is that this
method is not static
which means it's using some
instance field dependency of this class
and so i would see that because i've got
you know this handy little underscore to
help indicate which of the ones that are
private fields here so that's the http
client dependency
so looking at this method i want to
figure out where should this logic
belong
and the way i can decide that is looking
at
what is this method most related to
one of these things being passed in
or something else entirely
so i look at member
and i say okay
how is this method using member
well it's only using to get the email so
like just to get a piece of data out of
it and then call some other web service
members probably not a good
choice for me to move this method to
also it's using a web service like web
services and domain models don't really
mix very well so
that's probably not a good place to go
offer type is going to have the same
sort of issue they're like it's just
grabbing one piece of data out of there
so that's probably not a good candidate
for me to move this method to so that's
probably not a good thing
so okay if it doesn't belong in
the member object doesn't belong the
offer type object could i leave it here
i could
but that would make that that would make
unit testing this method more
challenging
because
because mocking out like this individual
http client is a bit more challenging
than say trying to encapsulate this
entire method in some single thing so
let's do that
let's encapsulate
and extract this method into some other
object that would make our lives a bit
easier to test
so i'm going to extract a class
from this individual method
and it's got some let's see we want to
first name this
and the name of the method was calculate
offer value if we're going to turn that
around and name it give that a noun
we would call it the offer value
calculator so let's call it that offer
value
calculator
it's got some red here saying like uh
do not let's see
how to extract that
so uh the tar the desk the original
class had this http client field
i don't want this new class to reach
back over and grab that hp client i want
to be passing it through to the class
itself so i'll do that
and the other next thing is this method
is private and so we'd want to make that
public
because
of course we do
all right so that method just
disappeared
and then if i scroll to the top
aha now we have our offer value
calculator with our private read-only
http client field being passed our
parameter being passed in a sign there
and then the method itself
looks exactly the same with the slight
difference that's this method is now
public
now coming down to my assign offer
handler
it still takes an http client and then
here it will new up the offer value
calculator
so what i've just done though is i've it
created a class from this one method and
this right now is going to be a domain
service so domain service is one of
those classes that deals with domain
objects it's it's coordinating between
them but it's not like uh it's not like
necessarily mutating them directly or
it's not mainly dealing with that so
that's what i've just created here is
one of those domain services
now this hasn't helped me in my unit
testing yet
so
in order to make it easy for us to use
and test we want to extract an interface
from this class so let's do that now
i'm going to extract it oh no not super
class
extract an interface
i offer value calculator sounds good to
me
all right so now we have the interface i
offer value calculator and this class
implements it i'm going to change the
name of this though i hate
class names that implement an interface
that just have the same name minus the i
it doesn't tell me any clue about how
this implementation of this interface is
different than anything else or what the
kind of special thing it's doing so this
one i'm going to be calling the web
service offer value calculator
if i actually no let's not rename that
if that was tied to an actual specific
third-party web service i would put it
as part of that like i don't know
there's
salesforce opera value calculator
whatever
i would i would put that in the name to
tell me you know this is the strategy in
which this class implements this
interface
okay so we've got this interface
so the next i'm going to
do is this class in the original
transaction script doodad is still using
the derived implementation so i want to
fix that
i want to say
right here
by highlighting the type there's this
refactoring and resharper that says use
base type where possible
so it will look to see the usages of
this field and say wait a minute can we
use
a lower type
if if possible and what this will tell
me though is um like i guess the old way
i would do this i would just change the
type of that to the i offer value
calculator and see what breaks this is a
little bit more intelligent about that
probably not system.object that would be
silly we'll use the i offer value
calculator
leave the other options alone
all right so i was able to do that
safely
now the last thing we want to do is it's
not passing it in as a parameter so
let's fix that
so i'm going to say
introduce parameter
and we'll still call it the i
offer
oh no
offer
value calculator it also tells me that
there are parameters that can safely be
removed again because i don't have any
tests around this so there's no actual
usages of this constructor so
we'll fix that here in a second
click next
value yes it's warning me i need to fix
that i will and the last thing i need to
do is
make that the interface type and i'm
good to go
almost
there is a way we can fix this so i am
using dependency injection so i'll go
real quick over here into startup
and say
services.add.http
clients of the i offer value calculator
to the web service offer value
calculator and then i might have to fill
in like the actual you know
host information there but i'll leave
that i'll leave it blank for
just to be easy on ourselves
okay
so we took that one method that was
dealing with some external web service
we extracted it into a class
thereby making a domain service and then
created an interface around that one
method so that
uh in order to unit test this i could
then mock out that one single method
if i had unit tests but i don't that
would make this talk go way too long so
just pretend like i do
all right
so that fixed this one method
now i've got these other two
so let's go into the first one calculate
expiration date
okay so
looking at this i see that there's one
parameter being passed in offer type
i also see that
it's static
which means there are no
there are no dependencies that this
method uses so everything that it needs
to do is contained inside this method
using that one single parameter
now the first thing i see is a little
squiggly note here that says
uh use
switch expression so let's do that
because that's
that probably oh that's much nicer isn't
it
uh let's see can i can make this even
better can i do this
oh yeah inline that can i do this
oh okay so it that whole thing could be
converted into one single expression
pretty nice
now um looking at you know where could
this method live
again it could stay right here there's
no
uh
i don't i don't have to move this method
somewhere else i feel like that this
logic really belongs to this class
however i do notice that it's static so
it's not using any of the instance
properties and this method only deals
with that offer type object
and in fact it deals with it
quite a lot
one two three four four places that it's
using that object and so this is a code
smell
this is called inappropriate intimacy i
wish there were a better name for that
but it's
a method like touching another one a
whole lot um
and so i see this when it's when it's
when it's when it's
poking into this other object for all of
its information to perform some logic
that's a clue that like maybe this logic
better belongs over there so let's put
it over there
now i used to do this where i would like
go through several steps to eventually
get over there but i'm going to go like
the cheat mode and make this much faster
there's a refactoring and resharper
called make method non-static and this
is a kind of like a supercharged like
perform multiple refactorings all at
once
and so what this what this does it says
okay you have a method that's static
right so how do you make a method
non-static you convert it into an
instance method
but where should that instance method
belong what we'll do is look at each of
the parameters and say you know do you
want to move it to this individual
parameter as the destination for this
non-static method
now if i make this method non-static on
the
uh instance parameter here
then it can also convert all those
usages of calling into that object it
can make this now just like instance
property references instead so let's do
this and see what happens
make method non-static
i have to select one of the instance
parameters here
there's only one so that makes it easy
oh method disappeared where did it go
over to offer type
so a few things it did one it made it
public because it had to in order for us
to call into it from somewhere else
and notice that all the offer type dot
went away
instead of like calling out into the
other object asking it for all this data
and said
it's calling just directly into itself
which means that all the cat this uh
this this logic is now encapsulated
inside of the thing that it most deals
with
that it's most concerned with
so that's a fairly like safe refactoring
and fairly straightforward like now i
actually have a behavioral domain model
because i've got a method
on my domain object that that deals with
its own behavior like all the logic to
calculate this expiration date is now on
the thing that has all the information
about how to calculate the expiration
date so i think that's pretty cool
all right so let's go back over to
assign offer handler
all right um
this is kind of a little weird now um
i'm getting to the point where i'm by
the way that this this original
refactoring where i had method method
method
uh that i've extracted out that was
known as the compose method refactoring
where i i kind of take you kind of think
it's like a table of contents of a story
where instead of having like a big wall
of text like reading charles dickens or
something then it said you break those
individual parts into like the the major
components that they're dealing with and
then the method names kind of have those
like title chapters um that give you the
clue of like what this logic is all
about um but we know so kind of we're
kind of moving away from that because
now the methods are somewhere else so
what i often like to do here
when looking at the assign offer method
is saying well now i'm not really
following the composed method
refactoring because these methods no
longer all exist here they're kind of
scattered about instead let's do a
little bit of d factoring
now d factoring is just simply the
reverse of a refactoring so if i have a
refactoring of extract method
the d factoring would be to inline the
method
if i wanted to extract a parameter the
inverse would be to inline the parameter
and so each refactoring will have a
inverse to to or a reverse inverse a
logical undo to kind of get it back to
where it was before or just to
just undo or or or
not really undo because i could maybe
not have done in the first place but in
any case
um i i feel like this is no longer like
the same level of uh
complexity for each of these methods so
let's let's inline this assign offer
method so we can kind of take a step
back to see all the things that are
going on
so for that
i will say inline method inline all
usages
remove the inline method declaration
and
i don't know what always does this but
it does
we're going to
get rid of that one
there's a reason why i did that why
there are two parameters just because
the method originally had one inside of
it and so this is just still preserving
that behavior just in case there was
some difference between those two
okay
so looking at this
i can see like well there are a few
things going on here i've got again the
calculating the offer value that's
separated out in its own method i've got
calculating the expiration date and i've
got then the assigning of the offer
itself
so if i were to look at this and then
say well what should we then
extract into a method to eventually move
somewhere else
you could say let's do all three
like maybe i can maybe i can get all of
these out into its own
its own method and then put that into
like refactor that somewhere else
or i could say maybe just this stuff
because this is all dealing with like
just in memory stuff i'm not reaching
out to some other web service
that seems like the most appropriate
choice for now but we will we will
actually try in a second to pull it all
together to see what that looks like
so
i'm going to pull all of these together
extract a method
assign offer and what we'll just say is
like calculating the expiration
expiration date is just another step in
assigning offer to a member so let's
just like pull that in as part of it
and the parameters being passed in are
the offer type i'm going to move that up
because i like it the member the offer
type and then the value of the offer
all right now the reason why i'm doing
this where i'm extracting the method
first is again because i just want to
understand what is the data that's being
used what are the objects being used by
this block of code and it's really hard
for me to just look at a block of code
and just kind of
think that i understand all the things
that are going on but by extracting a
method it kind of sets it in stone that
says yes this is actually what's being
used um this is what this is the inputs
being passed in these are the outputs
being passed out and these are any kind
of dependencies being used by having
this intermediate step of extracting
into a method makes it much easier for
me to grok and understand
what is the what is the logic of this
section of code here
okay so we're going to have the same
exercise we did before we're going to
look at each of these objects it's being
used and ask ourselves are any of these
a good candidate for us to move this
behavior to
now this one's a little bit different in
that it also has an output
value that is also part of the domain so
that is
also a valid choice to look at for where
should this behavior live
so
i've got member
we can count one two three usages
okay offer type
two usages and one of them is just part
of an assignment to something else so
that's probably not a great one
and then finally offer down here
so it instantiates it
then then assigns it to the other thing
and then returns it
so
member and offer both look like decent
candidates because they have a similar
number of usages like member had three
usages one two three and then offer as
kind of three well two usages really and
admitted returning it
so then i look at what is the nature of
this operation like who who should own
this operation of assigning an offer to
a member
should an offer be responsible for
assigning itself to a member
i mean that's kind of i guess it could
but it's a little bit backwards in my
head
instead i think of like if i want to
assign an offer to a member
i see a member there and i'm going to
hand them the offer and say now you you
sir uh you sir now have the offer
and so that's how it kind of matches in
my head and so that's where we'll try to
do it
so again what we'll do is do a
refactoring to say make method
non-static
it asks us which of the instance
parameters we want to try to move it to
and again we can actually try each of
these we could go offer type what does
that look like
it looks horrible undo
what we'll do instead is just pick the
one that makes sense remember
it went away
all right so going over to our member
object
now we have all the logic to enco to
assign an offer
uh to a member all fully encapsulated
inside of this one single method we give
it the offer type we give it the value
and then it does all the logic in order
to assign that offer to the member
and now our method
looks pretty small now we have just
one thing that says calculate offer
value and another thing is to assign the
offer to the member
now i'm going to do a controversial step
here some people like it some people
don't but i just want to show it
just in case some people like it
so right now the
the public quote interface
of
this object says
you give me the offer type and you give
me a value and then i will assign that
offer type to that member but it doesn't
calcul doesn't
encapsulate the nature of
how it calculates the offer value and
how it should calculate the offer value
for an individual member
instead i can give it anything
like
in 32. max value like i could do
whatever i want here um it's not
enforcing any kind of constraints about
how the offer value should be calculated
so there is a way around this
and what we'll do
is i'm going to first inline this value
here as a trick
to make my next step easier
and i'm going to go to the assign offer
method i'm going to say i want to inline
that parameter value
and by inlining it it will instead of
that you passing in the value directly
it will
take the places where it's actually
calculating the value and use that as
the way to put it pass it instead
so
inline parameter
and it's telling me that two new
parameters have to be created i have to
pass in now the offer value calculator
and i also have to pass in the
cancellation token because async
and
i also need to do this as async task not
tag structure i don't know what that is
of offer
okay so what did this do
probably something like half of you all
hate which is now i'm passing a
a
service into a domain object this is
known as a double dispatch pattern in
which i'm passing now in a service
object
to a domain object
and then that domain object would then
call back out to the service object
passing in the exact parameters it needs
to to be able to interact with that
domain service
so what this allows us to do is
encapsulate the interaction of our
domain model with these domain services
instead of having like calling code
doing whatever it wants with these
domain services this is all about like i
as a domain object really need to be in
charge of how i'm performing this
operation and so you give me the you
give me the thing that can call the
thing and then i will pass in all the
correct values in order to calculate
that value
and now
we await the assign offer uh method to
get the offer object and now we can say
like this operation is now fully
encapsulated
i just want to highlight this as like a
possibility i don't recommend it in most
cases unless you really need to have
control over like what you're calling
there or especially if you look at
a set of logic they're like you're
calling the domain service like
somewhere in the middle here and you got
stuff above it and stuff below it so
it's really hard to like extract out
that one piece from all the others so if
it's really difficult for you to like
you know either pass in all those values
of parameters or there's a lot of
interdependency that's gonna say well
just pass in that domain service to your
domain model itself and let it do the
work rather than you trying to like like
jingle the thing out of there to to make
it happen
again it's not something i do often but
it is something i keep them kind of my
back pocket
in cases where the logic is just too
intertwined with domain services
some people don't like this
and then a domain model
i don't care
like async is the thing that we do these
days so it doesn't bother me if i'm
if i'm not depending directly on like
you know the uh salesforce offer value
calculator it's going through this
interface
this is just a way of encapsulating the
full and complete logic of what does it
take to assign an offer to a member in
one single method
okay
so what's next
we've got everything encapsulated but i
wouldn't say that our domain model is a
quote fully encapsulated domain model
because
over here i can do like wonky things
like
uh member that's a
number of active offers equals
n32.min value
probably not something we want to let
happen right like
that's an important value that needs to
stay correct it's one of those
invariants in my domain model that
always needs to be consistent and by
just letting anyone do anything with
this then uh i'm not able to
ensure that that value is always correct
now you could say well you know if we
just are really diligent about pull
requests and code or views then that
should never be incorrect and like i i
would say to a point but but again like
if i'm trying to
describe for uh
my fellow developers like here is the
here's the
there's the capabilities offered by my
domain model and there's no guard rails
about what you can or cannot do then we
have to rely on like tribal knowledge to
understand what is possible in our
domain so instead of like having this
tribal knowledge i want to really
codify that
in our code itself and not have it just
be like in our heads
so the first thing we'll do to to fully
encapsulate our domain model is try to
decide what are those invariants in each
of these different objects what are the
things in those objects that if i took
one of those things away they would no
longer be that thing like when does a
zebra become a horse
when you remove its stripes and so we
try to find those things in the model
that if we took it away it would could
no longer represent that concept
of our model to our business
so going back to our member object
i would go to the business and ask them
looking at each of these different data
properties here each of these different
pieces of information
which one of these could i take away and
it'd still be a quote member
now i will play the act of
the business owner
um and so looking at this to say um okay
first name and last name we do need to
know who you are because we have to put
your name in the email um you know like
a little header there uh so we do need
to know your first and last name we also
need to know your email as well because
that's part of the you know part of you
signing up as you give us your email you
get you know added to this mailing list
that if you cancel it takes you know 21
business days to get off of and so you
need these three pieces of data in order
to be a quote valid member
now the other two a little bit more
technical like they don't understand
like oh i have to have this assigned
offers property but we know like well
you know you have to have those other
two as well
so
let's codify that as part of this to say
when i
create a member actually it's not do
let's create a constructor
create a constructor
and the things that you need as part of
being a member our first name last name
and email
and we'll do this thing where if the
first name is
uh no then we'll throw an argumental
exception i guess if we're going to be
in c sharp 11 we can do this
right
grumble
but if you didn't understand that by oh
god it's coming
all right so you have to have a first
name you have to have a last name you
have to have an email and the last thing
we'll do is get rid of these public
setters because we don't want anyone
just go mucking around with all these
values do private set private set
private set
now right now you don't see usage of
this like in a fully fledged application
you would see usages of these setters
because there's probably a screen
somewhere of changing your first name
last name there's probably a separate
section for changing your email so we'd
have to go fix those as well but because
it's only a couple use cases
that's all we get here
similarly like here uh we'll get to this
one later all right so we got first name
last name and email
um okay let's also do then do the offer
object
let's go to offer
all right so we have member assigned
offer type expiration date and value so
i asked the business like well what of
these is like necessary for you to
for you to be an offer they look at to
say well all four of those all four of
those are absolutely required for us to
have an offer i can't have an offer like
not assigned to a member it's just like
floating in the ether um it needs to
have a value they can't like write in
their own value later they can't expire
forever so we need to have an expiration
date so all these things are required
check branch no why not
and then the last thing is let's go
ahead and make these private setters
because we don't want anyone coming
around and mucking with our junk
all right the last one is going to be
offer type
similar exercise
they would need all four of these things
so i'm just going to leave that alone
because in addition to time you get the
idea
all right so to make sure everything
works let's go ahead and compile
oh no
we have lots of things messed up now
okay so first thing we have is the
property or index or date expiring
cannot be using a good as no said okay
uh oh that's something else we'll come
back and fix this
um oh yes we needed to convert this to a
constructor so let's just do that real
quick so we have new
offer that is let's see this
then offer type then date expiring
and then
value
oh no not that one
let's extract a
value here extract a
variable
and then now this is going to be
value
okay
so that wasn't too bad
um okay let's compile again
oops
so this one's a oh this is a totally
different a totally different
transaction script we have going on here
so this is one we actually did need to
mutate
the expiration date
so let's do the same
exercise we did before look at this
method seeing what are the different
steps involved see what methods we want
to extract and then move those methods
to the appropriate location
so we first see
data access junk like not gonna get away
from this that's okay i just i never
really refactor that it's fine whatever
so it's going and getting outs
item members it's going to go load up
the member object
next it's going to find the individual
offer
out of the member assigned offers
okay
it's going to
set the expiration date for today oh yes
so this is the expire offer handler so
this is also about expiring an offer now
expire the offer
i guess because like if it's a bad offer
or something like that they'll say okay
it's it's expiring today and you can't
use it anymore
and then finally it goes around with the
number of active offers so let's extract
this into a method
to see what information it uses now i'll
call this the
expire
offer
method
okay so it's still dealing with this you
know red squiggly we'll fix that here in
a second
um but it's also let's see it's got this
request oh i don't like that i don't
like it when it's like dealing with this
request thing let's see if i can extract
a parameter for the places that uses
this one value
so we'll call it offer
id and it tells me i can safely remove
the request object i'm doing this
because i don't if i'm going to move
this method somewhere else i don't want
to necessarily deal with these like dto
things so let's convert these to
parameters to make our lives a little
bit easier here
okay so now it just passes in the offer
id property there and now this method is
a little bit more like like simple here
we're just doing member and the offer id
okay so looking at this we have the
member object
i see two usages
well i'm i can't move this method to a
guide that doesn't make any sense
um
and so i could also look at well what
about the offer object i would have to
extract a method for just that one part
and then but that that would be kind of
weird to have this like
chain set of methods here so
doing refactoring here i say make method
non-static
i select the instance parameter member
click next okay that went away
now it's still red here and this is
because this date expiring uh is still a
private uh
still private
setter on that object
so what it can do here
is refactor this one single line of code
and then i will move this
i don't need this question mark go away
do this again make method non-static
because it's just dealing with the offer
object
so now
this member object says okay firstly to
load up the offer i'm interested in
expiring i will tell the offer expire
and then finally i will decrement my own
number of active offers so it's this
aggregate is then like
interacting with its own
child entities in order to perform this
overall operation uh first finding the
offer i'm interested in
and then
doing all the logic necessary to expire
that offer which includes interacting
with another thing as well as
interacting with my own stuff as well
do we ever make this oh this should have
been private too
that would have also made our red
squiggly before
all right so at this point offer now has
a fully encapsulated model like
everything's private and the only way
allowed to mutate are through the public
methods or public instructors as part of
it
yes there's like the
like this compiler gets confused with
the private sets i'm probably i'm using
in any framework so i still need these
private setters that's just a small
concession uh in persistence ignorance
it's fine with me i don't care
and the last thing is in my member
object
all those operations are now 100
uh fully encapsulated with the exception
of
this thing so this is the last thing
we're going to fix is this public list
because we don't want people to do this
member dot offers
dot clear
like that would freak our business owner
out like what do you mean you can just
like wipe a person's records of all
their different offers like that
shouldn't be ever possible so the last
thing we want to do is encapsulate all
the usages of
someone just going in and setting
everything here and instead making all
those operations against that collection
completely encapsulated inside this
model
so in order to do that we need to
convert this from this like auto
property thing to have an actual backing
backing field so let's do that
and
somewhere i need to do the magic
refactoring
maybe i do this
nope
if i can't get in the next two minutes
that's fine here we go
uh we'll just do it manually there's
like a magic place i put my carrots in
order to
create a static or create a um
uh
convert this auto property to
oh there it is god i got it finally it's
your property with backing field
ah finally
okay
um so now i have a property with a
backing field
um i want to remove this setter because
i don't want anyone to be able to do
this so i'll have a yeah we won't allow
anyone to set this
to expression body property
and
this will now become
whatever we want like i enumerable is
okay we can do
i read only collection maybe that's
better for folks
and then
this is now a private read-only
read-only list of offer that i'll only
allow this one class to be able to
mutate the assigned offers
and so down here where was going to that
property instead
i go to
that instead
and now i can say yes indeed
this domain model is now 100
uh fully encapsulated
how many of you like hated this part
this this part right there
i figured so so you don't have to do
that it's just throwing out there is a
possibility it's okay
all right
so
we took
an application that was using just plain
transaction script patterns where it was
just
database database access database access
a bunch of business logic and by using
the techniques of these two books we lit
we we found code smells and used these
refactoring techniques to slowly push
our business logic down into our domain
model whether it's in the domain
services or in the actual domain model
itself and then once we're able to push
that behavior down and found that all
the usage of the domain logic was in the
domain that then led us to be able to
incorporate this fully encapsulated
domain model where everything was
private and only the operations that are
possible through the domain
are exposed on the domain
so thank you all very much if you want
to see the code behind here the before
and after you can go by my github
github.com presentations otherwise uh
have a great rest of the conference and
thanks for coming
you